what's going on guys I actually was just
finished actually didn't really finish I
just got into guardians of the galaxy I
am going through and I'm writing the
script for Age of Apocalypse part 3
which we're finally getting around to
doing that again and I'm trying to
figure out how to word it but I figured
while I was trying to gain my bearings
I'd sit down and watch a little bit of
guardians of the galaxy which it's
really bad because like I have really
bad a TD and so I can never like sit and
do anything for any prolonged amount of
time like I'll sit down and I'll start
watching like guardians of the galaxy
and then I'll be like okay like I need
to like work on age of apocalypse and
then I'll start working on a tree
apocalypse and then i'll be doing that
for like a few minutes and then i'll be
like okay I got to do something else
like I could never just like sit in
focus which is like wild yeah i got my
ps4 going when like I'm I've got destiny
I probably play destiny here in a little
bit if any of you guys want to play
destiny for a little bit while I'm at
when we're done with this send me a
request my friend list is actually full
on on ps4 so on send me a send me a
message like I don't know I don't know
senton and just say hey like I want to
play a destiny or something like that
and I'll invite you to play with me so
um I do so like I want to do level 32 of
the prison of elders so we might get
around to be able to do that so anyway
um yeah it's uh it's funny is he walked
into the chat I want you to put my music
okay
I'm listening to tiesto from museum
plane amsterdam in 2006 queen's day one
of the best sets he ever put on but
anyway um again for youtube channels
again we always sort of talk about
YouTube channels we kind of discuss some
YouTube channels that are worth checking
out this was actually a little bit
different this time of course I've got
robbed explains in the bottom this so
you guys can check out my new channel
where I just plain stuff outside of
comic books and then um there's also oh
god what oh evan handyside but for those
are the guys who were curious about the
music that I used in my video about the
importance or why how it was that Civil
War saved Marvel the link for the guy
who makes that music is in the
description and he's actually really
really good at it like I really enjoy
the music that he makes so so definitely
check that out because he's he's pretty
solid like he usually does covers and
stuff like that but he's really solid
and I really enjoy the music that that
he makes so i'm guessing e-cigarette
juice on my my desk I hate that like
when somehow it gets on your desk and
you don't know how it happened it's just
like there no I won't be at e3 but I
really really want to go like I'm really
psyched about what they're gonna be
doing with with a lot of the games the
rumor is it supposedly um God who was it
it was a bungee I don't think but that
one of the companies whoever was it made
dishonored that they were basically
going with you like the rehearsal and
they demoed the reveal of love
Dishonored 2 so I'm kind of on the fence
about that I wasn't a huge fan of the
first dishonored I didn't play it like
religiously I'm just kind of like mad I
mean it'sit's you know cool but there
wasn't anything like outrageously
amazing so um okay so how do I find new
music for my videos honestly I just it's
a combination of two things one is I
have an agreement sort of with
monstercatmedia the monstercatmedia is
an electronic actually we just started
zan zan be no I guess um monstercatmedia
is a company that puts out like
electronic music and stuff like that but
most of the music that I get comes from
there and I pay like like eight bucks a
month or something like that and I can
use any of their songs for
I guess I can monetize any other songs
on my youtube channel so I think it's
actually really cool DFC to me like
companies like Sony and those guys would
be much better off if they did that if
they said hey hey us like like 15 bucks
a month and you can use any of the songs
you like the sony music catalog on your
YouTube channel they make so much money
like you would be absolutely ridiculous
you have billions and billions of
minutes so I guess of hours of video
uploaded on youtube every day like think
of all the money they could rake in but
they're too boneheaded to make that kind
of a decision so um anyway so yeah um
that's that's the answer that the other
thing is whatever i'm looking for like
hip hop music like I prefer downtempo
hip hop music I prefer sub that's not
like super ridiculous I like stuff that
kind of has that jay-z jazzy kind of
feel to it it's kind of hard to describe
but for example jay-z song can I live
like that is one of my favorite types
like favorite sounds of hip-hop music
i'm most def you know Talib Kweli i
guess black star in mother I guess love
to leave kweli and mos def as black star
common you know those are some of my
favorite forms of hip-hop where it's not
like rapping about guns and mobs and you
know getting women stuff like that you
know it's it's like hip-hop with a with
an actual purpose to it and that that's
what I prefer and so I usually just jump
on YouTube and I'll send like a message
off to the person or I'll post a comment
saying hey do you care if I use this and
usually like I don't care like let's see
my channel and they'll be like oh my god
this guy's got 300,000 subscribers yeah
dude you can use it just like tell
people you got it for me which makes
sense so um let's see why is Thor
unworthy we don't know actually I'm
gonna keep my jug of water right here we
don't know why Thor's on where the
immortal hasn't told us no I don't watch
the NBA I prefer NFL and college
football Marvel hasn't told us why Thor
is unworthy we have no clue like all we
know is that he's just not worthy they
may explain it to us at some point um I
have no doubt that Jason Aaron will be
like hey guys here's the reason why I
Thor is not worthy but for right now
they're not telling us and so we're just
kind of it's kind of a thought though we
may never find out to be honest where we
might find out I have no idea but either
way you know
we we just don't know um let's see hope
with the venoms to be it has it happened
um I don't think so but I'm not the most
knowledgeable about the history of the
whole venom symbionts I know enough to
say to like hold my own in a
conversation but I'm not like a
specialist in the the symbionts i think
that the carnage symbiote either in some
kind of an alternate reality or in the
main reality they had like taken like I
just bonded with all these different
superheroes and stuff but again I'm not
really sure about that my favorite genre
of music um it's kind of a mishmash EDM
is definitely up there and then like
hip-hop is up there with it so um let's
see what song did you use in on the
secret wars probably three video please
answer I have I don't even know what
that song is I don't know I don't
remember what song I used um let's see
Thor became unworthy became worthy again
and time runs out when he fought to be
honest actually he didn't he didn't
become worthy um what they would happen
and we actually I think we explain him
if we explain this or not um Thor and
the multiversal Avengers had traveled to
date when they were going through the
incursions they had encountered an
alternate reality where there was a
hammer that was made explicitly for
people who were unworthy and that's the
hammer the floor was wood and that's why
it says you know whosoever holds this
hammer if he be unworthy shop that's the
power of four and then he yeah yeah
you're actually right yeah he became
worthy again once that was over he was
able to live he wasn't able to lift the
unworthy hammer he could lift the
regular hammer but it didn't matter
because they died immediately so but um
Tiesto I love this I love this mix it's
freaking amazing am I excited for true
detective yes oh my god the first season
a true detective it was mind-blowing
like Woody Harrelson and Matthew
McConaughey that was one of the best
rules I've seen Matthew McConaughey in
at a long time when I saw that that that
series I was like oh my god mind blown
like okay Matthew McConaughey solid it's
one of the best things I've seen him in
since the time to kill to be honest and
that's been a while
um let's see shouldn't Marvel with
Disney be able to make a great animated
films where is a second where is the
product we deserve and need well I don't
know visually anything that people
deserve I mean I don't think of anybody
is really like entitled to anything but
I mean the one that you guys want I
guess I in truth marbles doing quite
well with live-action films there's
really no reason to make an animated
film at this point they may I mean I
don't see any reason why doesn't he
wouldn't somewhere along the line but
right now they don't really need to and
so there'd be no reason to have it c-rob
what book is jonathan hickman going to
work on at DC Comics I have no clue and
Jonathan Hickman may not even know what
the way things are running at DC comics
DC probably doesn't even know I have no
idea I have no clue what he's going to
be working on um I mean really him going
to DC Comics is a rumor yes remember
I've been hearing this room I've been
going by you know I'm not sure if it's
been confirmed I don't know if Hickman
himself has been like I'm going to DC
Comics he may just go somewhere else you
may go to like velvet I think South said
he might go to like velvet or something
like that but either way you know he's
leaving marvel so we know that for sure
let's see wait technically if you pick
up the unworthy hammer doesn't that mean
you are worthy no the Hammers designed
for people who were unworthy whereas the
normal hammers is on people who are
worthy so they're two different things
hey Rob what is the oldest comic you own
um probably this one fantastic 481
number two the one I keep on display um
that is well no that's not true that's
not true and you guys are you guys are
actually going to like you guys are
going to be amazed by this um I own well
it's really worn out and a really crappy
condition and I keep it in the end long
boxes but I own a copy of amazing
fantasy number 15 so i paid like
twenty-five hundred dollars for it it
was it was it was a lot of money but i
really needed it so I like keeping that
stuff away like I like keeping it you
know because the problem here is if
somebody like broke into my
house and I had all these comic books
that I worked all this money story
around here I mean I would be I'd be
devastated it would be absolutely awful
and so instead I just kind of keep it
all can find you know keep it keep it
all sort of sort of hidden away people
are saying the video is kind of buggy
here's a video buggy at all for you guys
I mean it shouldn't be bugging out too
much although it does look like it's
kind of flickering a little bit I don't
think there's I don't know what to do
about that I don't know how to fix that
but YouTube's been implementing a whole
bunch stuff to you like the chats
different all that kind of stuff so
maybe they screwed up live streaming I
have no idea but um anyway I don't want
me I don't think it's I don't think it's
that big of a deal i think people don't
really don't really care that much um
let's see yeah i was actually kind of
kind of on the fence about whether or
not i was going to do comics and coffee
because i was like i really do work on a
troll tacos part 3 but i love comics and
coffee i love talking to you all so I
figured you know why not why not you
know just do the last gym it's only an
hour out of the day and I can hopefully
force myself to like you know work on it
so um let's see it went from what and
we're from tin okay I was over streaming
a 1080 in the first place so there's no
way away from today is you 40 but let's
see the thoughts on Punisher being in
daredevil okay so we talked about this
during the weekly pool and I am psyched
I mean it's the perfect testing ground
for the punisher the having the punisher
featured and i'm actually not drinking
coffee I'm drinking water so having the
punisher featured and is like basically
like having a cameo having a few
appearances in some other person's
netflix series is a great way to gauge
like audience reception because they
don't have to invest millions and
millions of dollars or i guess however
much money they have to invest to make a
Punisher TV show they can literally just
bring
bring John into the Argus spring they
got a plate of the plates promo I'm not
referring to him by John alike referring
to him by his first name because i don't
know if it's kind of weird but they can
bring the actor into the daredevil
series they can gauge fan reaction and
then decide whether or not they want to
actually have a TV show based on him
from there and so again you know it's
it'll be interesting you know either way
it'll be it'll be it'll be solid I think
I doubt that will be disappointed I
don't think that we're going to sit down
and say oh my god like this sucks you
know this is awful I don't think it's
gonna be taught that I think we're gonna
be like this is amazing okay so Rob why
is it the MCU and the disney XD TV shows
on battleworld their alternate Earth's
right shouldn't they belong there um it
seems like what Marvel's doing is
they're basically saying that they're
there comic book universe is separate
from all other forms of media the only
exception of that is Spider verse we saw
with spider verso they actually brought
in different verses of spider-man from
like the animated cartoon show from the
1960s which was dumb you know and stuff
like that so you know they brought in
some of those some of those bigger
things but you know what the rest of the
Marvel Universe yeah I don't really I
guess the Marvel Comics I don't really
think we've ever seen an instance where
we've had characters you know for
example like like spider-man or I'm
sorry like non spider-man characters who
have been featured as part of the non
Marvel Comics universe encounter book
form I could be wrong but I don't think
I've ever seen like x-men the animated
series encounter book form will see that
with X benign t2 but we've never really
seen that before with anything else so
so anyway let's see um raw what do you
would you ever do Green Green Lantern
world try I was actually about doing
that I was thinking about doing emerald
Twilight because I mean that's Kyle
wehner that is you know oh my god Kyle
Rayner he gets Hal Jordans ring and
becomes like super cool after that you
know he's like the new Green Lantern I
thought about doing that um you know I
may or may not it really kind of depends
at this point it's it's okay here's what
I want to pick your brain about this I
wanted to talk to you guys about this
so the the video that I did about how
civil war saved marvel um what do you
guys what you guys think about that you
know what you guys think about like the
audio and different things like that you
know I want to get your l's opinion on
that because what I'm thinking about
doing is transitioning my marvel
explainer I guess my comics explain
videos to like that format where I have
more of like a narration more like a
mini documentary kind of format where
it's like you know me just basically
telling you guys exactly what's going on
you know explaining everything but
having this sort of documentary feel to
it so so let me know you know how you
guys how you guys feel about that will
you get emergency awesome we're working
on it um and things are looking pretty
good you know i'm not going to sort
anything will tell you guys anything's
happening for sure just saying we're
working on trying to get emergency
awesome on the podcast but he is if you
look at his uploads and you look at when
he uploads and you look at what it is it
he talks about how topically is that
guy's schedule is stupid busy so that
guy was it was it was it was crazy but
um let's see what do you think will be
the new Marvel movie after the ones that
have been confirmed I don't know that's
that's that's yes the big problem is is
phase 3 we know what that is we know
what phase 3 it's going to lead up to
the infinity war that's that's phase 3
the face for that's going to be the
tough one you know I mean where do you
go from there I guess you have the
Inhumans take a more they take a larger
approach maybe you bring like the entire
secret wars element from the comics into
the movies I'm not really sure how all
that's going to play out and it's really
going to be tough to do I would say that
that most likely what will happen it
will at least hopefully by that point
marble will in some capacity have a deal
worked out with Fox well they'll be able
to use the x-men and the Fantastic Four
and if they do then it's going to be
solid if they do it's going to be those
are the characters that we're going to
see in the new films so you know I'm
hoping that happens I'm hoping that's
what we get but again there's there's no
real guarantee about that so
um ever thought about recording destiny
not really i mean i'm gonna cali book
channel not a gaming channel so i don't
really I don't really do gaming that
much you know it's not really my my
thing which by the way um if you guys
ever get a chance check out a guy called
chess T's 187 here on YouTube he does
like like battlefield and stuff like
that but he's actually got a pretty
entertaining game place so I'd say
definitely check that guy out he's if
you guys like video games that guy is
definitely worth taking a look at um
let's see scroll back up scroll back up
the scroll leg up aah oh God which side
am I on for Civil War am I Tony Stark or
MRI Captain America which side do i pick
hmm you guys are probably gonna be a
you're probably gonna be a little bit
like oh my god yeah but I'm team Iron
Man I think he made the right call I
think Iron Man made the right decision
because here's here's here's a stance
that I take yes freedom is cool and
Captain America's like yes pro-freedom
and all that kind of good stuff yes
freedom is a necessary aspect for the
thriving of any organized society but of
white uses freedom to a society that
destroys itself if society would use
that freedom to destroy itself of what
good is freedom I mean more important
than any one individual or country is
the survival of the human race if the
survival of the human race means the
strict and you know I guess harshly
enforce adherence to a prescribed set of
laws then that's what it takes because
the freedom that was demonstrated and
over the course of Civil War the freedom
that we saw the circumstances that led
up to the implementation of the
superhuman Registration Act was that
superheroes and supervillains we're
blowing stuff up they were tearing they
were destroying cities people were dying
I mean they were just involved in these
colossal conflicts and so the problem
was that something had to be done
because if something wasn't done either
society would destroy itself or humanity
would step in and we would see a days of
future past kind of scenario taking
place
and so I think Tony Stark made the right
call he did it wrong he did it in the
worst way possible but he made the right
decision captain america i think was the
one that one that was a fault because i
think captain america was blind to the
fact that society would destroy itself
he said well we need to have freedom at
all costs even if it means our own
destruction like that's a that's a
ridiculous idea to have so um let's see
in all new all different Marvel should
they give uncanny back to Claremont
finally give him the freedom he wanted
in the 90s well i don't know i mean i'll
tell you right now i doubt that they
will give the x-men back to chris
claremont and here's why chris claremont
has considered the x-men writer i mean
no matter what chris claremont does when
you went to DC he wrote the sovereign
seven when he came back to marvel he
wrote extreme x-men I mean no matter
what it is that he does you know even
with the book City publishes you know
the the fiction of fictional novels the
problem is that he is the x-men writer
God loves man kills Days of Future past
the Phoenix saga all that stuff was
Chris Claremont everything that happened
in with the x-men from 1974-75 all the
way up till about 93 that was all chris
claremont and a combination of john
byrne and gimli the issue is that if
they said okay chris claremont writing
the x-men again expeditions are going to
skyrocket because chris clemons going to
write good stories he's not going to
write crappy stories he's not going to
show his own name for the sake of Marvel
and so it's going to absolutely
absolutely like take off in terms of on
the second let me see this is actually
240p people are saying this is 240p it's
not 240p if it's 240p that's that's
that's an issue on your part it's not an
issue 1 anybody else is part of it
anyway he's not going to he's not going
to tarnish his own name you know he's
going to he's going to basically like
you know work and create good stories
and because of that x-men are going to
sell and so they're not going to give
the x-men to somebody they can write
your stories it's like like the indus
forever when model was getting rid of
the Fantastic Four they did in two
stages the first stage was killing off
the Fantastic Four and the second stage
was giving it to a crappy writer
that's how they kill the Fantastic Four
and no one really cares about fantastic
four stories anymore I mean when was the
last time you guys went out and bought a
fantastic four story that's my question
but yeah I'm sure one to 720p if you
guys can't see in 720p and that's that
that's that's something else going on so
let's see do the characters in battle
world no other versions of them exist
like she hold okay see here's a really
cool thing about battle wool and we'll
explain this you know and and we might
actually do a video talking about battle
world in and of itself like explaining
battle world because again we've gotta
wait for sick of wars to finish you got
away for all the times to finish before
we can do those tie-in stories I mean
again we'll be doing Secret Wars as it
goes along but in terms of like the old
man Logan stories in terms of like
infinity gonna stuff like that we have
to wait you know for those two for those
to continue on before they before they
start before we make videos on them but
what we know is that in battle world
everybody knows everybody else is there
a force knows that there's planet hulk
you know old man Logan knows that dr.
doom is God and that there's you know
all these things going on they may not
know about the Ultimate Universe
characters that showed up out of the
life raft they may not know about the
earth-616 characters it came out of the
life raft you know all they know is that
all these other people exists out there
and so I would say that the incredible
hold all versions of The Incredible Hulk
reside within planet hulk that seems to
be the case now that's not confirmed we
may see another version of the
incredible hook somewhere else it's
entirely possible but you know I mean we
know for example with the old man Logan
story that at the end of the old man
Logan graphic novel the original or I
guess the main story that Logan or I
guess will rain killed all the horse and
they referenced that but all the other
versions of The Incredible Hulk that
we've seen so far are in Greenland lie
guess that's where they all are that's
their home that's your location we
haven't seen any incredible hooks
outside of that so again it doesn't mean
we won't and we may see that once battle
war comes to an end that things just
sort of begin to mesh together and sort
of work together and then we'll see
different characters spread throughout
the you know banner world itself and
maybe even other realities as opposed to
you know just this what we have here but
nonetheless you know who should be the
next spider-man well initially i heard
was supposed to be asked about her fuel
but apparent
he's not in the running anymore so I
don't know um I mean he was my pick you
know he was a solid solid person to play
the role of spider-man of Peter Parker
so I have no clue you know who that
character is going to be now um I don't
know at this point I have no idea I
still think they should go with Miles
Morales but you know again I could be
wrong here so I think Miles Morales
would be a great Miles Morales would be
a great takeaway from tradition I mean
spider-man fan's love Miles Morales
unless you're like a really hardcore
Peter Parker fans doesn't like change
like Miles Morales is a great character
and I think that them like breaking away
and saying Peter Parker's not going to
be this is not going to be Peter Parker
spider-man this is going to be Miles
Morales it will give them a chance to do
a more modern take on spider-man it'll
give them a chance to feature you know
more more realistic characters I think
that's going to be an awesome concept so
anyway um let's see the actor left in
the running our life changers yeah well
Marvel and DC do a crossover well i have
no idea i mean they have in the past but
i don't think we'll see them do a
crossover anytime soon as much as it
sucks to say that and as much as a
crossover would rock I don't think were
going to see them do a crossover
together which I'd love to see them do a
cross server I would love to see them
get together and do something like that
but again we're probably not going to
see that it kind of sucks but i don't
know i mean let's see Rob should the
punisher had been cast with a black
actor for daredevil I mean I don't think
so I mean I know the comic you're
talking about but that was a one-off
that's that I mean that's no that's not
going to happen
uh Rob what do you think will happen
with a last will rain do you think they
will go for a specific story line I
don't think so I mean I think that that
they'll keep it they'll keep the trend
going can I explain secret wars in 60
seconds or less uh yeah I want me I
guess I could um yeah I mean I could
explain seeger where's the 60 seconds or
less I mean hold on let's wait to the
clock turns 25 24 shouldn't be but you
know a few more seconds it's even at the
longest 30 seconds ever I mean I can't
it's I mean I should be talking about
the original Secret Wars that's the one
that I'll explain in 60 seconds or less
but I mean it wasn't it wasn't that
complicated it was pretty
straightforward come on clock a watch
clock never ticks or whatever that is a
watched pot never boils that's what the
that's what the phrase is a watched pot
never boils as soon as you walk away
just BAM immediately starts boiling so
for 20 vape no not at all not a not
inhabit celebrator for 20 okay so the
secret wars was basically a circumstance
where by the beyond er which was the
result of energy from the negative zone
creating a life in and of itself within
the Marvel Universe he basically was
curious about good and evil he's curious
about why good guys fought bad guys so
what he did is he took the most
pronounced superheroes and the most
pronounced supervillains he put them on
one planet and made them fight each
other whoever was wouldn't that won the
fight would basically get whatever it
wasn't they wanted over the course of
the conflict Doctor Doom actually stole
the power of the beyond or made himself
a god and then lost the power to the
beyond her again when the beyond her
took it away and Marvel to introduce
some characters they introduced like you
know Julia carpenter is Spider Girl and
or Spider Woman and stuff like that and
that was it I mean that's there's not
much to the original Secret Wars I mean
it's basically fighting and some stuff
happens in spider-man gets the venom
costume but that's it like that's your
60-second explanation of Secret Wars
1984 so it just hailed as a classic
story because it's their will is
actually the contest of Champions is the
first crossover of Marvel Comics but it
was the first like huge massive you know
Galactic's fan and cross over the Marvel
had had or at least is considered to be
and so um anyway um hold on a second
let's okay uh Rob if somebody made a
sinister six movie would that be a part
of the MCU I doubt it Sony making a
sinister six movie is going to be
laughable at best and so I would say
that that that's no I don't think that's
going to happen if they made a sinister
six movie I wouldn't go see it and I
would really hope they would not bring
it into the into the into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that's not what I
would really want let's see show the
punisher be portrayed as a villain for
daredevil season 2 or immediately be an
antihero immediately be an antic well I
mean the nature of him until I think
that it would be kind of a gradual
process like when daredevil first learns
about the punisher he's going to think
he's a bad guy and then I think once he
learns about the backstory of the
punisher then he'll become an antihero
he'll understand it'll be like us as
fans like for those of us as fans you
know we were reading reading The
Punisher stories when Punisher first
appeared in spider-man number 129 I
think it was he was like I'm gonna kill
spider-man and that was it we didn't
really have like a backstory we didn't
know a whole lot about what was going on
it wasn't until later on you know when
of course the story's been retold and
like welcome back Frank and stuff like
that but you know when it's when his
story was told to us then we were like
oh this is a guy who's just pissed off
of the world because his family got
smeared in a king gangland shootout well
that sucks and that was it like we
understood where he was coming from and
so he'll be an antihero the entire time
it's just we're going to see it through
the eyes of daredevil and daredevil is
going to see him as a villain and then
eventually understand his
and then see him as an antihero I think
that's the best way to go but again
Marvel's writing this story so I have no
idea what direction they're going to
choose let's see do you think in the
future model will get the rights to
everything x-men fantastic for Deadpool
etc and reboot the MCU I think so I
think they'll come a point where Disney
will realize that the amount of money
they were spin to get those rights back
versus the amount of money they would
make that they would make a lot more
money in the end they would they would
make some I mean imagine like a
marvelous in right now we know that
Marvel is coming out with a spider-man
movie I can tell you right I can tell
you right now without ever even without
even knowing what the plots going to be
about a marvel cinematic universe
version of spider-man is going to is
going to be a cash cow that movie is
going to make more money than Avengers 1
and Avengers 2 not combined but it's
going to make more money than both of
those films it's going to make so much
cash because people are like oh my god
like Sony keeps making spider-man films
I keep screwing it up even like casual
moviegoers you don't know anything about
spider-man or just like man this movie
sucks you know and so when Marvel's like
hey we're making a spider-man film
people are going to be like well I mean
look at like Iron Man Captain America to
Captain America 3 you know and like I
guess you know Avengers 1 and of
interest to myself they're going to be
like yes I'm still going to go see that
I'm just going to make a ton of money um
you know if they did that with like you
know Deadpool I mean Deadpool if Marvel
got the rights back to his character and
made a movie about him he's going to
cross over into everything even if he
only appears on a movie 45 minutes he'll
be in like every single movie and fans
will go nuts about it the x-men the
Fantastic Four it'll give Marvel a
chance to make the universe and I'm sure
they wanted to make all along as opposed
to being confined to like the Avengers I
think that that's that would be that
would end up being the cost but unless
you again you know we don't we don't
know I mean it could be that that Fox is
like if you want the rights back you
have to give us like 10 billion dollars
and that's just an assortment an amount
of money but unless you know it's
possibly just I mean Marvel and I'm
sorry Fox doesn't even have to give the
rights back as long as they keep making
movies the right stay with them and so
they can just keep cranking out crappy
movies with the exception of days of
future past and they'll keep the rights
and so there's nothing to say that they
only we didn't even give them back to
tamar ville so could Wolverine take down
Luke Cage that's a good question i
actually don't know the answer to that
question I know Luke Cage has
indestructible skin but I don't know if
its skin is indestructible compared to
Wolverines adamantium or if it's
indestructible compared to anything I'm
not really sure I'm not really sure how
indestructible his skin is I don't want
to even think that's ever been put to
the test so let's see hyperion was in
all new in the all-new marvel picture do
you think that they're wasting potential
to develop a new Avenger character
instead of a guy who looks like Superman
I don't think so because I period as the
closest models ever had to a Superman
character I mean you've got the century
but Hyperion has super strength he has
x-ray vision sort of speaking and like
see the molecular structure of things so
call that some version of x-ray vision
if you want to yeah he's got laser eyes
he's got flight he's super he has all
the powers of Superman basically minus
like frost breath I don't think he has
the ability to blow freezing breath out
of his mouth he's the closest Marvel has
to Superman without being a carbon copy
of Superman no way they're going to let
that go but they're going to key that's
why they brought back squadron supreme
or squadron sinister it's no accident
the squadron sinister is in the in the
the and Secret Wars I mean squadron
sinister was was never a significant
group they were never so big that fans
were just like oh my god squadron
sinister like what are they going to
make a movie about them you know it was
never they were never that big it's just
they're the closest thing that Marvel
has to what equates to the Justice
League of America in an evil form in the
Marvel Universe so hey Rob actual doom
or cosmic entities that's a question we
were asking in the podcast the question
we were asking is this is dr. doom in
secret wars actually dr. doom or is it
like dr. doom / molecule man is it
molecule man that looks like dr. doom
that made himself look that way and it's
pretending to be dr. doom is dr. doom
now a cosmic entity I mean I don't know
is you know if doctor if the cosmic
entities continued on it for some reason
they were able to exist could dr. doom
defeat the cosmic entities
powerful is he is he you know Universal
powerful or is a multiversal powerful
these are things that we don't know the
answer to I hope we get them and I think
Hickman will give them to us but we just
don't have the answers right now so um
let's see Rob do you think the century
can get a movie um I think he could and
I think it'd be good but I think you'd
be better off with a netflix TV show so
usually here's the deal guys Netflix TV
shows are far cheaper to make than
movies movies you're talking about you
know the money that takes to distribute
it you're talking about the money that
takes two to get people to produce it
you're talking about the money it takes
to pay the high caliber actors because
never many people are going to go see a
movie that has like low caliber actors
and so Netflix is the best way because
they can basically go to Netflix and
they could say hey make this TV show and
Netflix can make it for nickels and
dimes and produce a high quality TV show
so I mean it's I think I think it's a
much better call for them to give him
his own his own netflix show so um I
mean intrude I think that's the future
to be honest like Netflix like Netflix
originals that's going to be the future
of television that's going to be the
future of what leads into movie that's
going to be the testing bed for a lot of
Marvel stuff I think you know going
forward was going to start introducing
because the success of daredevil morrow
is going to start introducing a lot of
things into the netflix TV shows are
going to start introducing or injecting
you know characters that we wouldn't
normally see in a movie they're gonna
throw them in netflix and if people are
just like oh my god this is amazing the
model is going to be like let's make a
movie and if people are like men that
sucks mom was going to be like well
let's just kill that character off and
we'll never see or hear from him again
and that's it you know it's a smart move
to make so um hey Rob do you like the
idea of doom being God or do you prefer
somebody else I like doom being God like
I think it's a cool concept for doom to
be like the god of the Marvel Universe
so I guess this new Marvel Universe so
since we do have as we have a Punisher
to appear and the daredevil series do
you think we can see the punisher in
2017 spider-man movie I don't know I
don't think so um it depends on the
success of the punisher it depends on
how much people like him i mean i have
no doubt they're going to write him well
it's just we don't really know if people
are going to be receptive to the
punisher
so hey well i'm new to comics what's
storyline or hero should i start with
suggestions okay well model is basically
changing everything um with Secret Wars
read the original old man Logan graphic
novel jump into really just kind of pick
and choose what you want to read in
secret wars if you want to know how she
divorce came about read time rents out
by jonathan hickman which will be
available in trade paperback form
probably sometime in the next several
months if it's not already and then and
I'm really just kind of go for it like
that's really all you need if you're a
DC fan you know i would highly suggest
one starting with the current run of
superman and truth as far as i
understand it you can read that man
number 41 like its standalone like
it'sit's that's it like all you have to
do is read Batman number one and you
know everything that's happened so far
and that's that's really all you need
that's what Benny mentioned anyway so so
yeah I mean it's it's yeah i think that
that is that that's the best way to go
um with regards to anybody else I mean
Superman just lost his powers so that's
a really good place to start you can
really just kind of do some light
reading about Superman in this new 52
you don't really have to if you don't
want to yeah I'd say that him losing its
powers is a great way to kind of jump
into where things are right now and
definitely start with the newest run of
Justice League because that leads into
dark side Wars so let's see Rob what is
your favorite comic it's actually a
series of comics and it's the Pirates
that not the punisher it is the century
series the one where century first
appears it's like a five part series so
um see do you think original sin could
get a movie no not by a long shot
what's my vape mod this is a cig le 100
watt plus um what do I think of Jim
Gordon Batman uh I haven't read that you
actually didn't know that Jim Gordon was
Batman I am honestly I've been so busy
trying to keep up with like Age of
Apocalypse of secret wars I haven't had
a whole lot of time to read DC I need to
make time but I haven't had a whole lot
of time to see it yet so um I'll
definitely check it out and let you guys
know what I think what's my all-star
x-men team oh um the problem is there's
so many people who were overpowered okay
top five x-men members Wolverine Emma
Frost no Wolverine Jean Grey as a
Phoenix force probably like white uh
yeah why crown of the Phoenix the white
room like the white hot room Jean Grey
let's see those are two um Iceman Bobby
Drake storm and I don't know maybe
Colossus I'm kind of picking them off
top my head I don't really have a whole
lot of time to think if I thought about
it I had a whole lot of time to think
about it I could probably give you guys
a more in depth answer but you know the
top my head hello Rob at fox news is the
Fantastic Four movie rights do you think
Secret Invasion can be turned into a
movie now I don't think so cuz secret
evasion is just too big I mean it could
happen it'd be interesting if it did
it'd be a good way a wreck on everything
but I think people would say this is
dumb and people would kind of get upset
about it so why use a drill apocalypse
taking so long because we have so much
to do and in truth a joke apocalypse ISM
isn't as popular as I thought it was so
we're just kind of taking our time with
it
um let's see Rob if you were a superhero
what would your what would your powers
be what would my name empowers be um
hello my name would be but my powers
would be my name would be the cash man
and my power would be to reach in my
pocket and have how much money I needed
in any particular point in time like if
I walked into a gas station and I wanted
to get like 20 hours with a gas I reach
in my pocket and immediately pull out of
20 if I watchin to like Best Buy and
wanted to buy like a four thousand
dollar TV I could reach into my pocket
and have four thousand dollars like
Debbie my power so um do Asgard and the
other realms have a place in battle
world we don't know we see I thought we
were going to get that I thought we were
going to see that in Planet Hulk like I
thought that was going to be Odin like
the actual Odin and it turns out of
snacks so you know I thought that's how
it was going to play out so we don't
know I mean we we have no idea Rob who
is your favorite superhero this entry
well the century before they folded him
into the main Marvel Universe like that
you know when they took him out of
marvel knights and they screwed it up so
do you prefer the comic art styles of
the past 80s and 90s or the current art
style that seems a little more realistic
well in truth it depends I mean John
Byrne see I didn't really think about
this until Sal and I were talking and
saw was like dude look up some
old-school John Byrne and he sent me a
link to the true John Byrne when he drew
the Fantastic Four I think or something
like that and his art style was
incredible like his art style was
stellar at the same time you've got like
modern artists like jlee you've got
classic artists like Gimli for the 90s I
mean you've got some really really
really good art styles that are out
there um you know honestly I'd say it's
a mishmash of any one particular person
there's really no no absolute on whose
art looks better a different artist
wearing different things to the table
and not woka there's some our Styles it
just look like [ __ ] that are just like
garbage pardon my language but they're
absolute crap
and we know what those art styles are
but you know for the ones that look
pretty solid it's really just kind of
bends in the story I mean some art
styles are more conducive to stories
like artists a draw darker are better
when it comes to darker story that's why
Jay Lee with his art was so good with
regards to the century because it gave
you this kind of throwback and give you
this kind of you know like like the
century had a very dark mind you know
the void all that kind of stuff and as
art gave you this this kind of set this
mu this ambiance ever being a very dark
atmosphere a very dark mysterious kind
of atmosphere well you didn't really
know what was going on and it set the
mood really really well you know if that
art had been done by somebody else you
know if that are already been done by
like LaRoche or something like that like
I don't think it would have been as good
it would have been like mmm you know far
different so um is marble now all new
x-men good ah I really didn't care for
it to much but I've heard they've gotten
better in truth I kind of gave up on
all-new ax marbles now mobile now is all
new all different x-men I give up on
that pretty early on so I didn't really
didn't really enjoy too much um
spider-man ant-man after credit because
he hasn't said to be in civil war yet
and he is supposed to be in one movie
before his stand alone as far as I know
he's going to be in Civil War I don't
know why he wouldn't be it would make
sense to throw him at the end of ant-man
it gives him plenty of time but see they
don't even have an actor cash flow Roy
but they don't really need to they can
just kind of have a cgi scene with him
like swinging around or something like
that they don't really need an actor /
say where they can just like show
somebody's hand they don't have to show
a face there's a lot of things they can
do um that seems like it'd be the best
time to do it especially they want
people to go see a man see that's that's
a really good marketing gimmick if it
looks like the expectation for ant-man
is it going to be that good if Marvel's
looking at the at the discussion if
Marvel's looking at the talk and they're
saying well I mean people don't really
care about a man they can say hey guys
guess what spider-man that's going to be
at the end of an Matt and people are
just like oh my god let's go see it you
know and they're going to go see it just
to see spider-man at the end of ant-man
that'll be the reason to go see it and
it'll get people in the seats and that's
really the main focus of of the mobile
Cinematic Universe regardless of the
stories they tell us regardless of how
cool the depiction of a lot of the
characters are Marvel Studios goal is to
get butts in the movie theaters and they
do that really really well so um let's
see Rob do you think Captain Marvel and
Doctor Strange should appear in Captain
America Civil War not dr. strange really
um I Captain Marvel might she's not
really necessary he could replace her
with anybody in truth she was just an
Alana see and this is really probably
gonna make it make a few hardcore you
know capital mobile fans upset the only
reason she was in that is because Marvel
was trying to get her own solo series
that's it like she had a solo series
running and as soon as civil war ended
her solo series failed and they canceled
it so you know I mean people bought it
because it was part of civil war but
that was in I don't think it really need
Captain Marvel and I mean you need her
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe just
for the sake of saying hey here's one of
the most important women and marvel
comics but you don't need her you know
in the civil war film itself you could
replace her with anybody so um let's see
least favorite superhero um definitely
spider-man it's always spider-man bigger
spider-man sex I was watching the
amazing spider-man earlier actually and
I was like man this dude sucks like he's
fighting a giant lizard and he's using
webs and and I was like man he's like
struggling fighting a giant lizard like
like I can name so many people that
could destroy a giant lizard in the
Marvel Universe and this guy this guy is
just like struggling like having the
hardest time doing it and so I'm like
man spider-man spider-man sucks like
he's important because the legacy he
created but when you're talking about
like like how to spider-man compared to
like other people in the Marvel Universe
like he doesn't like he he crawls up
walls and he shoots wedding out of his
hands and like he's strong
cool I guess so um could you do a review
of dragon ball z I've actually been
toying with the idea of making a video
explaining Dragon Ball Z because it's
it's Japanese comics it's manga and
we're a comical channel why not so we
may be that at some point just kind of
as an experiment it's kind of a one-off
and see how it goes so hey Rob if mama
got the rights to the Fantastic Four do
you think it would be a good face for it
would bring a lot of content to the
table like a lactis they could I don't
really know I mean we've answered that a
couple times already they could but
again I'm not really sure how how they'd
be able to I'm not it'd be a lot to do
they have a lot to tie in so um let's
see uh captain hold on a second what was
that captain america and the punisher
all all must suck that nope the punisher
school because he's unique because he's
able I mean he's more capable than
spider-man is and he has no powers I
mean he could just like shoot spider-man
from a mile away and then spider-man
will be dead and that would be it and
and that's that because spider-man sucks
but like Captain America could easily
overpower spider-man and he did during
civil war so spider-man sucks um let's
see why do you hate on spider-man when
he could beat Wolverine any day he could
like spider-man has a healing factor
equal to Wolverine like you spider-man
has bones made of adamantium because
that's I didn't know that that's do um
let's see what do you think of
invincible iron man ah honestly Oh
or you take my invincible Iron Man's
like comic run or are you talking about
like like superior iron man because a
lot of people get those confused so let
me know spider-man has spider senses
though okay it still doesn't matter like
I mean if the Punisher okay if the
punisher was like a mile away and shot
spider-man's my man would be dead before
you heard the sound that killed him he'd
be dead before his spider sense even
went off because the spider sense has a
radius I mean it's not like spider-man's
like oh my god there was a plane
crashing that's gonna be like crashing
into me in like like five minutes and my
spider-sense goes off to alert me like a
spider since alerts above immediate
danger that's why I like he has that's
why he has such fast reactions it's not
like he's a fortune-teller you can't see
the future I mean a spider Matt doesn't
alert him that like in 10 days someone's
going to try to kill him it's not how a
sweater sets works so um let's see Rob
do you think the Inhumans could replace
the x-men definitely and that's what
Marvel's doing mom was replacing the
Inhumans are in place replacing the X
been with the Inhumans they're doing
that in the in the comics are doing that
in the movies like they're that's why I
say I'm all is probably never going to
get the right to the X been back because
it kind of just written them off but Sal
made a really good point the reason why
the Inhumans are coming out between
infinity War part 1 and infinity War
part 2 is because it's possible that
exponent pockets could fail and then mom
was like hey guys look if you want to
get rid of those rights you know we'll
go ahead and take it back and they'll
get them back and then they'll cancel
the Inhumans movie and they'll just or
they'll push the Inhumans movie back and
they'll launch an x-men movie makes
sense but let's see Rob do you know how
to speak spanish no i don't speak
spanish and my friends my French is
really really rusty actually that
segment on Rob explains rel was speaking
in French I ran that bye-bye Vinnie's
wife buys article and she was like well
I mean it's you know you did a decent
job you know I mean you didn't butcher a
too bad so um let's see did you hear
that James Gunn confirmed that Fox owns
came the copper no but I came to conquer
was never really at the top of my list
in terms of asking like
who owns King the Conqueror I mean I
never really thought about that too much
so all the Inhumans are coming out after
infinity ward off of the most they were
coming between parts one and two well I
mean it that's fine that makes sense
let's see am I allowed to post links
here no you can't post a link to the
chat um Rob loving the new channel I
appreciate it Ghost Rider reboot
thoughts are they doing one because I
haven't heard of them doing a
ghostwriter reboot and I don't think
they should I think rebooting ghost
rider would be a terrible decision I
mean no one's asking for it it's not
like people are like oh my god like like
we really need ghost rider in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like we really need a
man with a with a burning chain and a
flaming head riding around on a
motorcycle capturing demons like we
really really need to have that like no
one's who's asking for that that's what
I want to know it's century in battle
world not that I know of but again like
you know for those of you guys who are
who haven't had a chance to read secret
wars yet a lot of what's going on in
battle world is very new there's a lot
of things that we don't know the answer
to and so we may see him at some point
along the line or we may not who are the
Inhumans I have a video about the
Inhumans explaining everything you need
to know about the Inhumans let's see Rob
can Deadpool get killed and do you think
the a nose can can the stuff I don't
understand I understand your question
let's see do you think Iron Man could
take over as well as most popular
character
and face or do you think that it will
always be spider-man 2 over Oh it'll
always be spider-man spider-man is the
face of Marvel Comics like that's that's
just that's the way it is like
spider-man is the face of Marvel Comics
like there's no there's no two ways
about that I mean yes that's the way
it's always that's the ways i was going
to be I mean that's why whenever you see
a lot of comics a lot of the older
comics you'll see spider man's face
plastered on there because that's the
it's the face of Marvel what are your
thoughts on Jim Gordon being Batman I'm
not feeling it wondering if you got an
idea how long that'll last well again I
haven't read that yet but now as far as
I'm concerned like Bruce Wayne there's a
reason why they keep coming back to
Bruce Wayne there's a reason why John
Paul Valley played Batman and then he
left there's a reason why did Grayson
did Grayson played Batman and then left
there's a reason why a lot of these
these people have played the role of
Batman and then vacated the roll back to
Bruce Wayne because fans love Bruce
wayne/batman like that's that's what
they want they want Bruce wayne/batman
so we'll get Bruce wayne/batman back
eventually I mean it's I have no doubt
about that let's see will Deathstroke
ever get a feature film I don't know I
don't think Deathstroke will ever get a
feature film at least that long he might
if he did okay apex effect if you keep
doing that I'm just gonna ban you from
the chat so um no I don't think
Deathstroke will ever get a feature film
um I think that the Deathstroke getting
a feature film oh I mean he could and to
be cool you know and I would enjoy it
but no i don't i don't think that no uh
I don't know I hate questions that I
can't figure out where I guess questions
are kind of calm I don't know jester is
a great character Deathstroke is a
character who I don't know okay I'll
leave it to you guys do you guys want to
see a movie about Deathstroke that's my
question to you guys let's see the
century vs Superman that is an age-old
question my friend and that question
will be going on for a long
time I'd say Superman but some people
say the century so let's see hold on a
second let's scroll back up somebody
asked a question about in secret wars
number two were those dead bodies dead
Galactus bodies lying around the raft uh
I'm not sure what you mean oh um now
those were no I don't think so those
were the bodies of four of the four core
that we're lying rather they were
destroyed they were killed by people who
like nope they were destroyed by the
Cabal um yes yes people want to see it
yeah um Wow yes I want to see that it
would be great well I mean I guess
people like yeah so I mean do I know if
Hollywood reboots spawn I doubt and I
don't think there'd be enough to market
I don't think enough people would go see
at the two would justify the cost of
rebooting this series I mean he was just
there wouldn't really be any benefit to
it I mean I'd go see it but aside from
like hardcore comic fans I doubt many
people would really go see it at all so
um let's see I saw a list of possible
possible actors to play Wolverine on the
list was Norman Reedus oh my god I would
so go see a Norman Reedus Wolverine film
like I would love to see that like he
would be he would be intense like I'd
love to see him as a character
Rob favorite Marvel movies is currently
out um guardians of the galaxy pop my
favorite one so far let's see best Iron
Man suit probably the extremist suit
from superior iron man that's definitely
the one that I think is it brings the
most of the table what are you what are
your opinions on the current for run
well the Thorin woman was Thor run was
interesting until we found out she was
Jane Foster and it's not really that
interesting anymore so I'm not really
i'm not really that psyched about I'm
just kind of like well I mean that's
cool I guess yeah um do I think for in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
underpowered oh yeah Thor in the comics
this way is like way stronger and then
Thor in the in the model Cinematic
Universe like yeah yes it's yeah he's
very very very strong um let's see where
did you get your Hulk and Iron Man
pictures behind you they are awesome I
had those commission at New York Comic
Con thoughts on The Walking Dead spinoff
coming out soon I am really really site
um I mean they've had in the comics for
a while where they've had people on the
west coast but I'm really excited to see
how it happens in the TV show like
that's what I'm really really psyched
about so which I mean the walking dead
is a comic and we should probably start
getting into the walking dead sometime
soon so did they ever reveal what Nick
said to Thor to cause him to drop the
hammer no they never revealed that they
never told us what it wasn't happened
let's see which movie would be best to
reference the Netflix shows even before
character crossovers ah
hmm probably civil war makes the most
sense because civil war has all
different kinds of characters that were
part of it the comics it makes sense to
reference those even if they don't
actually have them in there they get
anyone when they're talking about
assuming that it goes by the basis of
the Registration Act they could say well
there's people emerging all over the
place that have powers there's this guy
in Hell's Kitchen that's fighting
street-level crime I mean everyone just
kind of go from there and that would be
that'd be really really cool so anyway
guys um we're going to go ahead and
bring this live stream to an I need to
get to work on Age of Apocalypse I think
I'm gonna play a little bit of destiny
so um if any of you guys want to join me
for a spot of destiny send me a message
on ps4 my ps4 handle is Marvel explained
and and we'll get together and play like
we'll play some prison of elders or
something like that so so yeah I'll
catch you guys later peace